joining me now is clay travis founder of
outkick.com and co-host of the clay
travis and buck sexton's show and olivia
rondo writer at the foundation for
economic education thank you all so much
for joining me uh libby i got to go to
you first
um why do they still have her out there
on the campaign trail or just
representing the country it seems like a
bad strategy
well the democrats strategy is to just
give them a nice face to look at so for
them that means a woman that means a
woman of color and so they think that
that's going to protect them from
criticism so they can just you know wave
their hands off and say oh well if they
criticize her it's racist it's sexist
but the truth is i'm not i'm not afraid
to say it the only reason she is even
the nominee that she was even the
nominee in the first place is because of
her race and sex i mean
joe biden said that to begin with i mean
that was her criteria but clay she's
become a liability it's bad for the i
mean the president's approval rating is
is bad enough but you can't get rid of
him he's the man you can't get rid of
the men uh so when did they pull her off
because it's not helping them at all
a couple of things one was it racist and
sexist for the democratic primary
electorate to overwhelmingly reject
kamala harris because that's what they
did she ended her campaign and democrats
like to think that they are beacons of
stability and truth and justice they
were not in any way impressed by kamala
harris and i don't think it was racism
or sexism on their part just like it's
not racism and sexism now on behalf of
the rest of the country the only thing
that is going well for joe biden right
now is that his vice president has a lot
lower approval ratings because if she
didn't there would already be talk about
biden stepping down and allowing her to
assume the role of president in the
weeks months and years ahead right now
democrats are terrified she may be the
only politician in america who's got
worse approval ratings than joe biden so
the only positive for joe is that kamal
is a lot less popular than he is yeah
she couldn't even defeat sleepy joe i
mean it's kind of sad when you think
about it but olivia i got to ask you
this why do they do this accent thing i
mean it's kind of insulting you got
hillary clinton that goes in the black
church and said i ain't feel no way
tired and then you got aoc saying there
ain't nothing wrong with that they just
all of a sudden want to feel like if
they talk like us which they're not even
talking like us then all of a sudden
it's going to make them relatable is it
desperation
are you implying that hillary clinton
doesn't normally say i have hot sauce in
my bag which is just around anyone
it's so clear to me lawrence and it's so
absurd that nobody else sees that this
code switching this pandering it's just
plain offensive and it doesn't matter
that kamala harris is a woman of color
we all know that she doesn't talk like
that when she's around you know white
people she talks to black people a
certain way and she talks to white
people a certain way and that's what
democratic politicians do they pander
now the thing is let's see if we'll
continue to fall for it because i can
see through the phony the phoniness
let's see if everybody else can too
clay i gotta end with you because you're
not really in the political space you're
into sports you're average day people
do you think there's a little bit of
buyer's remorse do you think that
they're going to double down and vote
for this administration again
i think there is a monster amount of
buyer's remorse in particular in the
independence in this country lawrence
because when you look at the data and
you saw what happened in virginia last
week the people who are running the
fastest from the democratic party from
joe biden and kamala harris are the
people who came to them the last right
independent voters suburban moms and
dads they were the people trying to
decide trump or biden they made a bad
choice i think there's a great deal of
buyer's remorse which is why i think the
democrats got their ass kicked last
tuesday and why they're going to get
even more of an ass kicking a year from
now in 2022 yeah the emotion just
doesn't work when people can't get basic
food items and get the kids presents for
christmas it just doesn't no doubt
anyway clay thanks so much olivia thank
you so much this is your debut on prime
time hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else